tu le président mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
michel raison permettez moi tout d'abord
de m'associer à l'hommage que vous avez
rendu au personnel soignant dans cette
crise dès avant cette crise qu'ils
soient médecins hospitaliers infirmiers
et oui vous avez raison il est désormais
nécessaire impératif de mieux prendre
soin de ceux qui nous soignent et c'est
en partant de l'expérience de leurs
expériences notamment pendant cette
crise que nous devons bâtir ce plan pour
l'hôpital que vous avez évoqué chacun
devra y être associée les partenaires
sociaux évidemment comme les collectifs
hospitalier c'est tout le sens de la
démarche que nous lançons que le
ministre olivier ferrand a lancé avec le
ségur de la santé une première réunion
se tiendra vous le savez je pense lundi
prochain et dès la fin du mois de mai
nous organiserons dans les territoires
en partant de l'expérience qu'ont vécu
les les soignants ce retour d'expérience
sur ce qui a fonctionné sur les succès
les réussites les attentes aussi de ceux
qui ont fait tenir l'hôpital pendant
cette crise cette crise a parfois
confirmé des choses que nous savions à
la parfois aussi bousculer nos
certitudes
elle a permis de l'inventivité de la
créativité des nouvelles pratiques c'est
tout ça que nous voulons
oui monsieur le sénateur faire remonter
des territoires pour bâtir l'hôpital de
demain
alors les français aspirent à une
protection sociale qui soit forte un
modèle de santé qui soit à la hauteur
qui soit efficace et le gouvernement
envie d'aller d'aller vite les
changements ne doivent pas intervenir
dans plusieurs années mais bien d'ici
quelques mois le ministre olivier
ferrand l'a dit en sortie de conseil des
ministres tout à l'heure nous n'avons
nous n'avons été ni assez vite ni assez
fort et c'est de cela dont il s'agit
désormais l'objectif est que ce plan
soit présenté cet été pour traduire tout
ce qui peut l'être dans le prochain
budget de la sécurité sociale et vous
aurez l'occasion ici d'en débattre
donc pas besoin de faire un diagnostic
le diagnostic il est connu il faut
désormais aller plus rapidement
il n'y a pas de tabou il n'y aura pas
tabou par exemple de l'articulation
entre le public et le et le privé et les
agences régionales de santé que vous
avez évoqué que vous connaissez bien
on sut aussi montré qu'elle pouvait être
en pilotage et en appui et que l'on peut
collectivement avec probablement des
améliorations gouverner en proximité
c'est donc bien l'histoire de santé
lui monsieur le président c'est bien à
l'échelle des territoires de santé qu'il
faut penser l'organisation des soins de
demain et nous comptons sur les
sénateurs pour y apporter leurs pierres
bien évidemment dans les semaines à
venir